So today we've talked about configuration, a kind of routine design task. We do
configuration when we're dealing with a plan that we've used a lot in the past,
we need to modify to deal with some specific new constraints. So for example,
we've built thousands of buildings, and thousands of cars, and thousands of
computers, and each of them is largely the same. But there's certain parameters,
like the number of floors in a building, or the portability of the computer,
that differ from design to design. So we need to tweak individual variables to
meet those new constraints. We started this off by defining design in general,
and then we used that to define configuration, as a certain type of
routine design task. We then discussed the process of configuration and how it's
actually very similar to constraint propagation that we've talked about earlier.
Then we connected this to earlier topics like classification, planning and
case-based reasoning, and saw how in many ways, configuration is a task,
while other things we've talked about provide us the method for
accomplishing that task. So now we'll move on to diagnosis,
which is another topic related to design, where we try to uncover the cause of
a malfunction in something that we may have designed. In some ways,
we'll see that diagnosis is a lot like configuration in reverse.